[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW SMITH: Well thank you.
I am Matthew Smith, and
with me is John Ryan.
And we are from Portland.
You can probably tell
by my metro logging
shirt, which feels out
of place a place up here.
But we're going
to talk about how
we have maximized our code
sharing between mobile and web
thanks to Flutter.
So a little bit about us--
we are a PaaS company
for developers.
And our goal is to make
enterprise software easier
to build, support, and deploy.
We have customers in
the commercial space,
customers like
Wayfair and Taylor,
higher education, some
great universities
like Yale and Stanford, and we
are also in the public sector.
We have research labs
and some municipalities
that use our software.
So all of these customers,
including about 100 others,
are going to be going live
on our latest platform, which
will include the
Flutter application.
The first customer going
live is going to be Taylor.
They are a 90-year-old
manufacturer
of restaurant equipment.
And this application will be
used in about 150,000 stores
in North America, including
like McDonald's and Wendy's.
So this is a big deal for us.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about our path to Flutter.
We started back in 2012, and
we wanted to be mobile focused.
And so we wrote our iOS app
in Objective-C. And in 2013,
we wrote our
Android app in Java.
We then rewrote our
iOS app and Swift,
and we rewrote our
Android app in Kotlin.
And then in 2016, we wanted
to add web to our platform,
so we chose Dart for that.
And now in 2018, we're happy
to say all of our clients
are written in Dart,
and we're in the process
of releasing that.
So why did we start
with native coding?
We started with native
coding because, for one, we
needed or applications
to work offline.
And this is a big deal
for our customers.
They're down in vaults.
They're in manholes, all kinds
of situations with no network.
And so this was a must have.
And because they're
working offline,
and they're dealing
with enterprise data,
they have millions of records.
So they're down
there and they need
to search hundreds of
thousands of parts,
and those parts need to be
available, cached offline.
And so that's a lot of
data for us to deal with.
And then we have to
deal with security
and regulatory compliance.
And we felt that we could
handle this best with native.
But this did create
a problem for us.
For each client we built,
it took us about 18 months
to build.
And then, when we
did those rewrites,
it took us about nine
months to rewrite them.
And on top of that, it's very
difficult to hire and train
developers on iOS and
Android, and especially
if you're trying to
cross train them.
So our solution
to this was let's
build engineering teams for
iOS, for Android, and for web.
As our product got
more sophisticated,
the time to develop
new features increased.
And we were developing
those features, of course,
three times.
So this problem just
continued to get worse
as we start to grow.
We were adding features.
We were trying to catch up.
And at the end of 2016, we
kind of looked at our platform
and we thought, well, we're
about a year behind of getting
these all up to feature parity.
And so this led us to
why we chose Flutter.
When we wrote our web client, we
really fell in love with Dart.
And we saw Flutter.
We were part of the community.
We had been watching it.
And we were excited about it.
But we found that breaking up
is a really hard thing to do.
We invested a lot of time and a
lot of money into our clients.
And this was a tough
decision, but Flutter
made it much, much easier.
And we still get to
see Swift and Kotlin
on the side for plug-ins.
We also found that, for
enterprise software and for us,
native coding for each
individual platform
is just not sustainable.
So what we did internally is
we agreed to a six-week project
to kind of test the
waters of Flutter
and make sure some
of the big questions
that we had could be answered.
And after just three weeks, we
had a functional Flutter client
working.
Obviously it wasn't
production ready,
but it was enough to
prove to us that this
is the move we need to make.
So we found, when we
started doing our Flutter
implementation, that most of
this code was already complete.
We had written our web client.
We had just finished that.
And basically what we
were doing was going in
and writing views for Flutter.
And because the hot reloading
stuff that you just saw,
building UI in Flutter
is extremely fast.
And so we didn't
quite predict how fast
we could build out our UI.
And now we're going
to get into how
we went about sharing our code.
So John's going to come
up and talk about some
of our techniques.
JOHN RYAN: Thanks, Matt.
So Matt mentioned that
three week number.
And it's important to explain
where that number came from.
It took a longer effort
over a period of time
to kind of massage the code
base and get it to a point
where we were ready to
implement our Flutter apps.
And when we thought
about this, we really
have tried to follow three
simple rules to do this.
We used layers.
So we thought of our
application as a layered system.
We tried to take as
much important logic out
of the views as possible.
And we also tried to inject
dependencies into our entry
points for our application.
So depending on what app starts
up, we can inject those in.
So let's talk about what
we mean by layers here.
Well, this is an example of
a non-layered architecture.
It's a simple Flutter
widget that you may write
if you're testing things out.
It queries Hacker News
and it calls setState
when you get the result.
But the problem with
this is that you
can't share that Hacker News
request if you're trying
to use it on web as well.
So each layer, in our mind,
can use the layer below it.
And, in general, it tries
to implement or interact
with the other layers
in an abstract way.
meaning they don't
concern themselves
with the implementation.
You may also want to do
this for other reasons.
The primary one is to
target web in Flutter.
You can swap the layers out.
You can use a different
view for Flutter,
and you can use a view for web.
And you may just want to
minimize your dependencies
between them and think
about the dependencies
of your application
and understand
each layer separately.
This lower layer,
what we're talking
about when we mean this are
things like Firebase things
like JSON over HTTP,
web sockets, and things
like caching on a local storage
or file system on Flutter.
So package:http also allows
us to write our services
in a cross-platform way.
It's a cross-platform
HTTP request library.
So our Hacker News service
asks for a generic HTTP client.
And then, when
our app starts up,
we know what client
to give our services.
On browser, we can
use a browser client.
And on Flutter, we
can use an IO client.
And this is awesome.
Our middle layer is where we're
going to be managing our state.
And it contains all of
our domain-specific logic.
And it interacts with the other
layers in an abstract way.
It doesn't concern itself
with the implementation.
Here we have a fancy controller,
and it asks for a view,
and it asks for a service.
And it's important to
note here that you can use
whatever architecture you want.
The important thing is that it's
separate from the other layers.
At this top layer, we
obviously use Flutter,
and we use Polymer
on our team, but you
can use any view
implementation you want.
And it also becomes easier
to switch between React
and Angular, for example.
There's a few patterns that
we found in our codebase
that we use a lot.
We think of our app in a
model view presenter way
usually, where the view knows
what it needs from a presenter,
and the controller can
implement that interface.
Or we have a view
model that is a shared
way of communicating
state changes
and updates with its view.
Or a view that implements an API
that is very clearly defined.
For example, a view
just emits events
and knows how to render itself.
What we mean by
having a simple view
is that it doesn't have as
much logic as you might put
into a view on other platforms.
And it implements an abstract
interface on Flutter and web.
So this process of moving
code out of your views
is just a matter of finding
the logic you want to take out,
moving it into the
controller or into a service,
and hopefully writing a
test as you're doing that.
As you're doing
this, you may find
that you're moving code
you didn't intend to move.
In this example, we have
a bunch of dependencies.
These are library imports.
And one of them is
importing Dart HTML,
and we can't import
Dart HTML in Flutter.
One way to quickly
diagnose this problem
is to build a test that
implements your controller.
So as you're moving code
into your controller
or your other state
management tool,
you know instantly whether
you've moved something
you didn't intend to move.
And you get a little
error here saying,
this code right here
is importing Dart HTML.
And that's the problem.
And you may just want to do this
because you want faster unit
tests.
Or you want to
build a command line
tool that interacts with
your services in the same way
that your app does.
Or you may just want a cleaner
library and package structure
that you can talk about
with your coworkers.
OK, so that's rule two is
to keep your views simple.
The third rule that we
noticed in our code base
is we inject a lot
of dependencies
and we just do this
in a simple way.
We have an app controller.
And app controller knows
what it needs to do its job.
In this case, it's
calling a service
and it's caching that data.
And it doesn't concern
itself with how the service
or cache is implemented.
So the two rules here
are pretty easy to follow
but hard to follow in practice.
It's just about
asking for things
and avoiding things
like singletons.
OK, so after all that
what you end up with
is, hopefully, a slightly
better architecture that
can be used cross-platform.
You have your
services at the bottom
that use a cross-platform HTTP
library or some other library.
And for things like
shared preferences,
you have an app that has
some thing the user wants
to save for their
use case, And you
want to use the shared
preferences plug-in on Flutter.
And you may choose to
implement that interface
with local storage on the web.
You have your middle
layer handling, hopefully,
your complex logic and
your state management.
And you have your view
layer that is implemented
using the same interfaces.
And it becomes very
clear the relationship
between these layers.
So let's go through an example.
A big problem for
a lot of companies,
unless you're at Google, is
deciding where to get lunch.
So we solved this problem
by building a voting app.
Our voting app is going to have
some state it needs to manage.
It's going to have a
few pages that it's
going to show to the user.
A user might create an
election, enter their name,
submit an idea, wait for other
people to join that election
and vote, and then
show the results.
So to do this, we can break
our app into separate packages.
We can have our shared logic
in our Let's Vote package.
We can build our
Flutter package.
And we'll have our web package.
Our Flutter and web
packages will just
import our shared package.
In our shared package,
we'll have some basic types,
like an election,
a voter, an idea.
And each class will know how
to serialize to and from JSON,
using the JSON
serializable package.
Now we need to
build our services.
This is an example
of our shelf server
that's serving our
rest end points.
So we need to build
a service for this.
Our service will use
package:http and implement
methods like Create.
So this will create an election.
And this can be
shared cross-platform.
This controller layer
will manage our state.
And it will have a reference
to the view and service
that it needs to do its job.
A quick side note here,
this is an example
of how we can test our
controller because we're
using dependency injection.
So we can mock a
view, mock a service,
and call init and verify that
we're doing the right things.
OK, so that's our
controller layer.
And for our view layer,
we need to wire up
that two-way relationship
between the view
and its presenter,
the controller.
So we'll call init in
our app controller,
and that'll expect an app view.
Then, in our Flutter
app, we can just
call things like
controller startbyCreating,
which will call the presenter
and create the election.
On web, we can do
the same thing.
So to make that work, we
implement our app controller
using various pieces.
And in this case, the only
piece that's different
is the client, the HTTP client.
On Flutter we use
a browser client--
or a regular client.
And on web we use
a browser client.
And you can see the components
here re implementing AppView.
It's implementing
that interface.
And on Flutter it's
implementing that state object.
The state object in
implementing the view.
Once we do this, we can
fix cross-platform bugs.
So as we were doing this,
we actually wrote a bug.
That's very easy to do.
We sorted the voters,
or the votes--
we sorted the ideas by the
vote, and we messed it up.
It returned the list
in low-to-high order.
So we need to reverse the list
to return the actual winner,
not the loser.
OK, so let's see a quick demo.
In this demo, we have our web
version running and our Flutter
version running.
We'll create an election.
And this will call
our REST services
using the same shared service.
It will call Create.
So Eric is going to enter an
idea for where to get lunch.
All the state management
in this application
is managed by the
same controller class.
Now Somebody on the Flutter
app is going to [INAUDIBLE]
the wrong code.
And once they enter
the wrong code,
the controller knows that
and can tell the view,
"I want you to show an error."
And on Flutter, you
call showDialog.
Now they're going to enter
their name, submit their idea--
sizzle pie.
And now the voting can occur,
and we can determine a winner.
All right, so problem solved.
[APPLAUSE]
So following these three
simple rules really
helped us think about how
to do this in a way that
was really effective and get
to that three-week number
that we showed.
The app is hosted on GitHub.
You can actually
use the app if you
go to that URL on the right.
And it's running on
a single instance,
so like most voting systems,
it's also not secure.
Be nice to it.
You know.
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW SMITH: All right, so
we are fairly new to this,
but we've learned
a lot of things
so far that we thought
we should share.
The first thing is we've
been able to share about 70%
of our code between
web and mobile.
And this includes our tests.
But this is a big number, so we
were really excited about this.
Going back over our development
timeline, iOS and Android
back in 2013, '14, '15, we
weren't sharing any code.
I have 15% up there
because we had some idea
sharing between iOS and Android
because Kotlin and Swift were
fairly similar, and
we were using Realm
as a cross-platform store.
And we were using RX, and so
you can copy some Swift code,
and paste it in Kotlin, and
massage it, and hey, you know,
share some of the same ideas,
but obviously not real sharing.
Now in 2018, 70% real sharing,
and all of our clients
are in Dart.
So going back to
the time it took us,
it took us 18 months
for each platform.
And a lot of that was we
were developing new features
as we were trying to catch
up our platforms that we're
developing.
So it's not like--
it was a catch-up
game the whole time.
Because we started building
Flutter so fast though,
what we decided was all new
features go in Flutter only.
And at the speed
we were developing,
we knew that was viable for us.
So now with our latest release,
there's no more catch-up.
We're done with that game, which
is very-- it's a big relief.
And also, 70% is a great number.
But it's not the amount
of code that you're
sharing that really matters.
It's what code you're sharing.
And what we're sharing is the
most mission-critical code.
It's the stuff that's dealing
with security, and persistence,
and talking to our services.
And it's where you'll
find most of your bugs.
And so it's also the code that
is the most expensive to write.
It takes your most
senior engineers.
And it's the most
expensive to maintain.
We also learned that hot
reload is the real deal.
So everybody sees
the counter going up
and the counter going down as
you change your code on the web
site.
And that's super
exciting, obviously.
But we have built
a big application
on this with a lot of state
and a lot of complexity.
And we use this
every day, and it
has made a world of
difference in our development.
So much so that we develop
all of our features
on Flutter first because
with hot reloading
we can write it so fast,
and testing is so fast
that all we've got to do,
when we're done with Flutter,
is go back and implement
the view on web.
So it's really, changed
our approach to this.
We are developing features at
three times the speed we were
before, for obvious reasons.
We're not writing
it three times.
And this is a real number.
Our features are
of higher quality
because we are testing better,
we're all reviewing each others
code, and we're all
thinking about the problem
in the same way.
And we've reduced our
QA time significantly.
And a lot of this
is because, when
that logic is all contained
in the controller, before--
an update was made, you've
got to test something in iOS,
you've got to test
it on Android,
you got to test it on web.
And now we can communicate
to our QA people
that this fix was made
at the controller layer.
There's a good possibility it's
fixed across all platforms.
And this has really
sped things up.
And probably the best
thing about all this
is that the three
teams that we've had
are now one big Flutter and
web team, all writing Dart.
And so this has been one of
those things that sounds great,
but you just don't
know how much--
it's just so exciting to have
everybody on the same page.
We sit down and
we plan a feature.
And everybody is
equally involved.
There's no miscommunication
between teams.
And we're all thinking
about the problem
from the same perspective.
So this has made us
very happy developers.
And our team's very happy.
And so we love it.
We wrote some more information
about this on our blog,
so you can check that out.
We wrote a Maps
plug-in, and also John
has a code sharing write
up that he did along
with some of the changes
it created in our business.
So that is it.
Thank you.
And definitely
check out Flutter.
It's great.
[APPLAUSE]